foreign
having just recovered from covid yes
kova do you remember coven things you
know I was gonna drop that into our
discussion here in a way that was going
to be surprising surprising yeah okay
well having just had covered it may
still be surprising to me at least
um not being entirely on my game
um
well I have stepped on uh on that
presentation but I will say
uh it is I had one
rough night treated it aggressively from
the get-go
I spent five days in isolation I'm
feeling horsey uh I did not take horse
Pace proper but I certainly did take
some medications that are well
understood by those who well understand
things
to to address coveted symptoms be useful
to uh treat a wide variety of problems
in both people and other organisms
including horses right including horses
right
um but anyway I will say I had a very
mild case it was quite annoying in the
sense of you know every time you get
sick with this disease you have to think
about how much uh damage it does and
although it's not a very dangerous
disease uh to those of us who are
healthy at this point it is certainly
does damage across a wide number of
systems which is troubling and you know
as we talked about extensively at the
beginning of the pandemic there is this
question those who called this thing
forth from a bat cave and enhanced it
have inflicted something on us
permanently and okay so maybe you get
covered every year or two and it
compromises a week of your life and
presumably for reasons that we will talk
about later on in the podcast
accelerates uh your rate of Aging across
multiple tissues I'm sorry is that can I
get a towel the cat just spilled a bunch
of water all over the deck
um this is not as bad as the pandemic
but it's bad besides with that if I had
my computer maybe about to Fritz out
because I got a situation anyway well
it's on the chords and so it's just you
can just throw it to me still that
purple gun okay just go ahead what were
we talking about uh you were talking
about yes we were talking about the
tissue damage but anyway my point is one
of the things that I said early on in
our discussions was that the cost of the
pandemic no matter how mild this disease
gets
is effectively indefinitely large if we
let it get to the point that we are
permanently stuck with covid and that is
where we appear to be it is now people
even people we're stuck with it believed
that it might be addressed and driven to
Extinction early no longer believe that
I no longer think it's possible with
current Tech to drive it to Extinction
and so anyway there's a point about what
if we just take all of my future cases
of covet until I am gone from whatever
uh thing ultimately takes me out right
how many weeks of my life are going to
be compromised by somebody's idiotic
decision to engage and gain a function
research on uh bad coronaviruses right
that's a huge cost even just to me
personally and then if you scale that up
across all of the people of the earth
who are going to be suffering from
something even if it's just cold-like
right if you have seven more colds in
your life that are the result of Anthony
fauci right that's a pretty big cost for
one dude to inflict on you personally
um for his own idiots see yeah and
that's that's the the least of what
might be going on and that is the least
and again as I will discuss later on in
the podcast a proper model of the
biology underlying this says that it's
not just the weeks that you lose because
you're sick that is all borrowing from
your lifetime capacity to repair your
own tissues and so the point is it is
accelerating your rate of death the rate
of the reason most of us do not reach
the maximum human age is that over the a
lifetime we spend the resources that
might get you to 120 fending off you
know flus damage all sorts of things and
uh anyway so they have now added another
one even if it's a mild disease that we
get periodically and it's just annoying
the cost is still arbitrarily huge
this is absolutely true and um and of
course it's also true that you know
it's hard to meet anyone now or to hear
of anyone really who hasn't had it at
this point and so you know many people
you know most people have some sort of a
mild case and and it's fine right they
appear to be fine
um with all of the caveats that you have
just made
um but even
then many many people will report
feeling like this isn't like other
viruses this isn't like either
respiratory infections that I've had it
feels different it feels it feels alien
in a way and you know of course it you
know it's it's a Franken virus so uh you
know that's not all that surprising but
the idea that it might it might just be
oh we've introduced another thing that's
going to circulate indefinitely and
you're going to be exposed to it and
you're going to get it indefinitely it's
really unlikely that it's going to be
that
that shallow a uh an impact so let's
just say uh what were some of the stuff
we're going to talk about today
um are some um you've got a couple
little Clips uh from the uh the
excellent John Campbell to show and
discuss uh some of the implications uh
with regard to uh covet and the pandemic
I'd like to following that I'd like to
talk about a paper
um
paper that was published I guess it's
last month
uh purporting to show that while
infections covered infections are higher
after you've been vaccinated than after
you've had coveted itself uh visits to
emergency rooms and hospitalizations and
deaths are higher among the UN among
those who have natural immunity but
aren't vaccinated as opposed to those
who are vaccinated so I just that seems
like a
that's certainly a very important result
if so and uh contradicts what a lot of
us have been suggesting so I want to
walk through that paper a little bit
and uh and then if we have time I'd be
interested in talking a little bit about
um stigma stigma and shame uh based on a
recent piece that I read and some things
that are sort of happening in in the
cultural space around around various
behaviors and predilections that people
have
[Music]